خطه شامله في اسطنبول لمواجهه زلزال قد
يكون كارثيا معهد الفلك ينفي حدوث هزات
ارضيه بمحافظات مصريه اسرائيل تفرج عن
تفاصيل فشل خطه اغتيال صدام حسين هذه
الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه
العربيه فاهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
نبدا من تركيا حيث اعلنت بلديه اسطنبول
الكبرى عن خطه شامله لمواجهه خطر الزلزال
المتوقع في المدينه الخطه التي تحمل عنوان
تعبئه شامله لزلزال اسطنبول تاتي وسط توقع
الجهات الرسميه والمتخصصين بالزلازل في
تركيا بان مدينه اسطنبول معرضه لخطر حدوث
زلزال كبير بقوه تتجاوز سبعه درجات ونصف
الدرجه على مقياس ريختر وهو ما قد يؤدي
لنتائج كارثيه مع وجود تقديرات تتحدث عن
ان عشرات الاف المباني في اسطنبول معرضه
للانهيار الكامل على وقوع مثل هذا الزلزال
بهذه القوه
بعدما افاد شهود عيان بوقوعه هزات ارضيه
قويه في العاصمه المصريه القاهره ومحافظات
اخرى فجر اليوم نفى معهد البحوث الفلكيه
حدوث اي زلزال في المنطقه وفي بيان رسمي
في بيان رسمي للمعهد اوضح انه تم رصده
اهتزازات ناجما عن اعمال انشائيه في
المنطقه من خلال محطات الشبكه القوميه
للزلازل مشيرا الى ان محطات الرصد لم تسجل
حدوث ايه زلازل واضاف المعهد انه لا يوجد
داعم للقلق بشان هذه الاهتزازات داعيا
لمسؤولين عن الاعمال الانشائيه الى توخي
الحذر واتخاذ الاجراءات اللازمه
بعدما ظلت سريه طوال ثلاثين سنه كشفت
وثائق مسلسل يبث في القناه الثالثه عشره
للتلفزيون الاسرائيلي تفاصيل جديده حول
فشل الخطه الاسرائيليه الاغتيال صدام حسين
عام 92 من القرن الماضي التحقيقات كشفت
انه يوم اجراء محاكاه لخطه الاغتيال وقع
خطا بشري فادح في التمرين واودى بحياه
خمسه جنود مثيره الى انه كان من المفترض
ان تكون المحاكاه دون نيران حيه وفقط ان
يتم اطلاق الصاروخ كرتوني تدريبي بعد ان
يتم اخلاء المنطقه لكن ضابط المسؤول ضغط
على الزر الخاطئ وقتل الجنود الذين كانوا
يمثلون دور مرافقي صدام دون ان يقتل
الجندي الذي مثل دور الرئيس العراقي
الاسبق
عاد الامير هاري ليتصدر حديث السوشيال
ميديا بعدما قرر الملك تشارلز تجريده مع
زوجته ميجا ماركل من مقر اقامتيهما
الملكيه واخلاء منزلهما في فروج مور كاتيج
لمصلحه شقيقه هذا القرار ياتي مع
الاستعدادات البريطانيه لحفل تتويج الملك
تشارلز في مايو المقبل فيما افادت صحيفه
ديلي ميل البريطانيه بانه وبغض النظر عن
انتقال اندرو من عدمه الى منزل هاري الا
ان الاخير مضطر برفقه زوجته لمغادره
منزلهما الوحيد المتبقي في المملكه
المتحده واستكمال اجراءات نقلهما الى
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وفي خبرنا الاخير اقترح العلماء ان
الادمغه الصغيره المزروعه في المختبر يمكن
ربطها معا في يوم من الايام لتكون بمثابه
اجهزه كمبيوتر حيويه قويه وفعاله صحيفه او
ضحكت ان مجموعه من الباحثين المتخصصين
وضعوا خططهم لتحويل الكتل ثلاثيه الابعاد
من خلايا الدماغ البشريه تسمى عضيات
الدماغ الى اجهزه بيولوجيه قادره على
المهام الحسابيه المتقدمه وهو مجال اطلق
عليه اسم الذكاء العضوي واشارت صحيفه الى
ان العضويات تشترك في العديد من انواع
الخلايا التي تمكن ادمغتنا من الحصول على
المعلومات وتخزينها